transcriptomics three is a course
dedicated to advanced methods of
analysis for transcriptomic data that
will allow us to find meaningful
patterns in data especially complex
patterns that are typically president
big datasets in this video we will speak
about unsupervised learning methods such
as clustering complex patterns that are
present in large datasets are hard to
find manually these types of data show
nonlinear dependencies and contain noise
that make it hard to find statistically
significant differences this is where we
can turn to automated learning which is
also known as machine learning here we
can train an algorithm or a machine to
perform tasks with data such as mining
for patterns machine learning can be
separated into two main categories of
methods both unsupervised and supervised
in machine learning
unsupervised machine learning focuses on
detection of patterns at data the main
idea is to apply techniques that are
automated and rely on various
assumptions about data to learn from it
the second main category is a supervised
machine learning part these methods rely
on availability of training data which
is data that has been labeled once a
data set of labelled data is accumulated
it can be used to train a model that
will be able to apply this knowledge to
analyze new data for example by
predicting its class in this course we
will start exploring different methods
for identifying groups of samples
without prior knowledge this process is
called clustering and then we'll examine
methods for developing classification
models from known samples in order to
classify data present that is in new
samples in this video we will speak
about clustering clustering gene
expression data is one of the most
useful techniques that you can use when
analyzing high throughput in alekhya the
data not
only can I help you find patterns in the
data that you did not know existed but
it can also be useful for identifying
outliers incorrectly annotated samples
and other issues that are hard to spot
with traditional methods with
unsupervised machine learning methods
we'll start with a data set which is
typically a table of elements such as
these shapes we can use a clustering
method for example hierarchical
clustering which is a method that seeks
to identify groups based on their
similarities we can also use a
dimensionality reduction methods such as
principal component analysis that we use
data variance to assign samples to
groups of elements that are present in
some cases we can use results to draw
other conclusions about the data within
such a structure in this case groups
based on the shape of elements within
the group this is the new information
that this technique will generate
principal component analysis uses
dimensionality reduction to show us what
the data variability will look like in
PCA we use the approach of principal
components that explain variance in our
data in the best possible way here you
see data with low variance the samples
are grouped close together and then
here's a sample with higher variance
however this variance is not well
explained by the X and Y axis but you
could draw a line through the original
space that shows a maximum variance of
this dataset this vector through the
multi-dimensional space maximizes the
variance of the data and is called a
principal component and just like with
the previous example we can add other
principal components such as PC 2 or
even PC 3 unless visualize our data by
projecting it into a space of two or
three axes that explain some percentage
of data variance when we select the
principal components that best explain
the most variance of our data we can
reject all of our samples into the space
and then visual as a full data set
this technique is called principle
component analysis and it can be very
helpful in the initial stages of our
analysis we can liken PCA to a
photographer trying to find the best
angle for a picture that will capture as
much detail as possible while showing us
the most information about the group as
a whole we would typically use this
method to visualize and explore our data
when using this multivariate analysis
method it's important to play around
with the data using normalization and
filtering while paying attention to
outliers for the best possible
interpretation but PCA does not identify
groups or their boundaries and that's
when we have to turn the clustering
there are many types of clustering and
hierarchical is one of the most popular
approaches because it allows clustering
on different levels let's say we have
our samples organized in some space so
imagine the PCA 2d plot where samples
are positioned in some perspective that
best represent the data variability the
algorithm would find the two closest
objects in this projection and then link
them together this is a cluster then we
would find the next two closest group of
two where any two linked objects are
considered as a single object and their
location is the center of that cluster
the algorithm will run until all the
objects are assigned to a cluster with
all the objects in it to run clustering
on the T by wooden foot platform you'll
need to upload the table of expression
that we generated from analyzing the
cell line data this data can be
downloaded directly from the lesson or
from a demo pipeline in the cell line or
in a seat demo the clustering methods
are located in the data mining section
of the platform hierarchical clustering
is an example of an agglomerative or
bottom-up clustering method starts with
attributing each sample to a separate
cluster it then finds the pair of most
similar samples and unites them into one
cluster
this procedure is repeated until coming
into one cluster that contains all the
samples the pipeline will take the
output perform clustering and then put
out the result in several formats that
we will discuss in a little bit but what
are the parameters the linkage parameter
determines the definition for measuring
inter cluster difference single sets the
definition as the distance between the
two nearest points in two clusters or as
complete defines the distance is that
between the two farthest points the two
ward methods are variations of wards
minimum variance method the distance
parameter specifies the distance metric
to use a measuring distance between data
points
these can be Euclidean Manhattan maximum
or kambera the clusters expected count
parameter sets the cutoff height to the
one of the results in a given number of
clusters do transpose allows the user to
transpose the input matrix to set where
the clustered objects or samples are
represented by rows or columns of the
input table we can use this clustering
to cluster objects or samples or even
features which are genes
what is cluster linkage well there are
several types the average linkage method
finds all possible pairwise distances
for points belonging to two different
clusters and then calculates this
average this method is less affected by
outliers than the others single linkage
uses the minimum difference to determine
clustering remember that this method is
also known as nearest neighbor
clustering the distance between two
groups is defined as the distance
between the two closest neighbors and
more formally it finds the minimum
possible distance between points
belonging to two different clusters this
method often yields clusters which
individuals are added sequentially to a
single group the complete linkage method
uses the maximum
and is also known as the furthest
neighbor or Maxima method this method
defines the distance between two groups
as the distance between their farthest
apart members more formally it finds the
maximum possible distance between points
belonging to two different clusters this
method usually yields clusters that are
well separated as well as compact the
centroid method looks for the center of
each cluster and then calculates the
distance between centroids of those two
clusters in addition to our decision of
linkage criterion for hierarchical
clustering we also need to indicate the
distance metric if euclidean distance is
chosen than observations with high
values of features will be clustered
together the same holds true for
observations with low values of features
remove that with Manhattan distance X I
and y i our x and y coordinates of the
if observation can mara is a weighted
version of the Manhattan the choice of
distance measures is important as it has
a strong influence on the clustering
results for most common clustering
software the default distance measures
the Euclidean distance
if euclidean distance is chosen than
observations with high values of
features will be clustered together and
the same holds true for observations
with low values of features the
hierarchical clustering algorithm is a
process and in this process the computer
uses the input file where columns are
objects and rows of features the
algorithm assigns each group to a
separate cluster and then evaluates all
pairwise distances between those
clusters using a chosen distance metric
it then constructs a distance matrix
using the distance values and then finds
a pair of clusters with the shortest
distance it merges them into a single
cluster and then repeats from step two
until we end up with a separate cluster
for all the samples or objects
with the k-means pipeline we inputted a
table of expression n dot txt format and
after running the algorithm we were able
to observe three different things the
first was that the k-means clustering
does not do a great job of clustering
next we found that basel will split into
two different clusters with cloud and
low and one and normal like in the other
and lastly we found that luminal split
into two different clusters our output
was a dot txt file as well with a
cluster ID the difference between H
cluster and k-means is that each cluster
has an output such as a dendrogram
that gives you the structure of your
data whereas k-means just gives you the
number of each cluster in each sample
this is a good example on how different
levels or Heights might have different
numbers of clusters or sub clusters as
we go towards the top there are less
clusters and the separation is going to
be stronger a good way to test
clustering models are to actually
compare phenotypical data with the
unsupervised classifications that we
create clustering is also widely used in
data visualization to organize the
patterns that we get into heat maps so
that we can visually see groups of
samples and genes in this section we
also spoke about different methods for
identifying groups of samples without
private knowledge we saw how gene
expression clustering is one of the most
useful techniques that you can use when
analyzing gene expression data not only
can I help find patterns in the data
that you did not know existed but it can
also be useful in identifying outliers
we spoke about several different methods
for clustering such as hierarchical and
k-means clustering and we learned how to
perform these analyses on the t bio info
platform in our next session we will
speak about supervised machine learning
as well as classification